[Music]
[Applause]
i spoke to darvin hamm yesterday after
the show the lakers head coach he won a
championship with the pistons he played
eight years in the nba he also won the
slam dunk contest back in 1996 he also
brought down a backboard he played at
texas tech they were playing against
north carolina in the tournament and he
brought down a backboard broke it he was
in the slam dunk contest and uh that was
the slam dunk that kobe won in 1997.
he's been uh around the league he was
with the bucks he was with the hawks he
was with the lakers and now he's back
with the lakers as the head coach and i
started the conversation by saying you
played against both kobe and michael
jordan how would you compare lebron
james approach to being great
to those two players um mike was the
trailblazer in the term of the type of
modern basketball we see the way he was
built his athleticism
is a multifaceted game the way he could
shoot the way he could play make defend
he kind of turned was a guy turning the
page forward to uh you know beyond the
magic and bird era and then you had kobe
who was like an offshoot of mike um
really really
eerily similar to to the same physical
makeup same uh type of playing style
uh so he
kobe doesn't get in my opinion enough
credit because he's so
uh much the prototypical michael jordan
guy like he's attached to michael
forever in my opinion but even standing
on his own he was able to you know
make leaps and bounds in terms of his
impact on the game and you know what he
was able to accomplish individually um
but lebron is just
like something we've never seen a guy at
that size that physical stature with
that skill set um
and the ability to play all five
positions it's like
uh lebron to me is like a new version of
magic johnson 2.0 you know it's it's
it's uh
i mean you
i you know i have this funny saying dan
to myself like every nba player has a
nba father
you know you look at kobe and mike you
look at to me magic and lebron you look
at dirk and larry bird like
everybody has a uh
uh nba nba father so
it's it's it's fun to talk about but
what lebron has been able to do in his
own era and and leading charge for this
new crop of young talent
is second to none i mean he's right up
there top five in my opinion of all time
you turn 49 next month why did it take
this long to get a head coaching job in
your opinion
i don't know you might have to ask some
of these ownership groups in some of
these front offices i don't you know i
had a young coach one time asked me what
does he need to do to uh become an nba
head coach i said well you're asking the
wrong guy
[Laughter]
i know how not to get a head coaching
job apparently
but uh you know it's everything has its
own time i like always say we're all on
god's time and sometimes you may think
you're ready for something but you know
it's it's just not your time the
circumstances you know are are various
in various situations
but i'm here now um i i feel comfortable
in the seat um i'm not
fearful or apprehensive about anything
uh
there's no perfect way to go about doing
this you ask all 30 nba head coaches and
they may give you a different answer on
what they need to do to be successful
and uh
i've learned a lot i've had the
opportunity to play and work alongside
some phenomenal phenomenal head coaches
so
i feel comfortable in my skill set i'm
gonna make sure we do our due diligence
and put a good staff around me and uh
and put together the best roster we can
possibly put together and and and move
forward one day at a time he's the new
laker head coach arvin hamm joining us
on the program did you keep any part of
that backboard that you shattered back
in 1996 like did you think about keeping
any of that
i do have a few uh pieces of glass and
in a little case uh in my man cave
what do you remember about that game is
against north carolina yes
it it it just
the one thing that always sticks out is
the way we were just counted out before
the tip-off uh leading up to tip-off no
one thought we had a chance and
they had a formidable uh ball club you
know they had vince carter antoine
jameson uh shimon williams jeff mcginnis
uh they had some really really good
players about four or five pros so and
here we are this little bitty team from
west texas who
had a great record but not great
recognition because of claim the fact
that we were in a very small market uh
so a lot of people didn't get a chance
to see us but
just that game started out just back and
forth back and forth and up until that
play you know it was a really hard
fought game and
once that play happened it just
completely shifted the momentum to our
direction so
um it was it's a great great memory it's
something i get reminded of all the time
i still get magazines to sign in the
mail oh cool i have people show up to
arenas talking about that play and it
gets mentioned all the time even 26
years later well if you would have done
that in the slam dunk contest maybe kobe
kobe wouldn't have won right
if i'd have taken my time in the slam
dunk contest i think i went a little too
fast but
i'm still bitter about being the only
one that
made three dunks and three really nice
dunks at that and didn't make it to the
second round so that was that was i
think the fix was on
help me understand
i think people expect you to fix russell
westbrook and at his age he's not
changing but but how do you what is your
game plan for russ and how to
incorporate him better into the laker
offense
i think the style of play we're going to
have you know all of those guys not only
just russ but lebron ad they're going to
be able to share the load and one thing
i mentioned the rust is the way i'm
built the success i've seen
especially most recently here in the
last nine years in the last 40 years
being with coach blood in milwaukee also
in atlanta but in milwaukee
one thing we always preach then we'll
continue to preach to be our foundation
of our teams is a defensive mindset
being able to defend at a high level and
i challenged him and he accepted the
challenge you know that's a part of the
worst sacrifice we use um and being able
to move him around in different spaces
on the floor as we go back on the
offensive end uh sometimes he's gonna be
off the ball slashing sometimes he's
gonna play in a dunker sometimes he's
gonna be initiating things he may post
up a little bit he may be the screener
and picking rolls so being able to
uh diversify
his his plan of attack where he's not
just rushing the ball up the court
facing three defenders every time
and having to you know put this like i
said the press conference put there you
could run to the telephone booth and put
their capes on like we need to everybody
needs to be involved with what we're
doing on both sides of the ball and i
think it'll make it easier uh lighten
the load and also allow us to get
stronger as the season gets longer
i've mentioned this before on my show
that the greek freak uh anthony davis
was giannis before giannis but it feels
like giannis has surpassed him why is
that
well i think you know it's a real part
of our game uh the element of injury uh
when you're not able to stay healthy
you know it it stunts growth but you
know i just saw anthony yesterday he
looks great um doing a great job taking
care of his body
and the key for him has always been just
to have him available you know if he
when he's healthy
he's one of the top
five seven players in our league and uh
you know the biggest thing with that is
again
lightening the load uh and making them
feel like they don't have to take fourth
quarter shots in the first quarter uh or
play playoff basketball in the first
month of the season
uh everyone has to pitch in and i think
different ways we'll move him around
defensively as well as offensively
will lighten that load a little bit
where he's not flying all over the place
having to cover for everyone defensively
or he's not taking a beating every
single play down the floor just trying
to iso isil iso like
playing faster offensively and again
having that
uh team pride and every man account for
one another defensively i think will
help him give him the best chance to not
only stay healthy but get back to that
championship level of play
that uh we've been accustomed to seeing
him do you care who wins the nba finals
not
really are you going to watch tomorrow
night
yes indeed
i'm kind of rude i have to be honest and
and laker nation don't don't beat me up
for this one it's more on a personal
level but
you know i love steve kerr um both of
those guys he and eme uh are extremely
good human beings uh but it's a little
something in me with email being a
first-time head coach and
doing what he's doing i think especially
his african-american coach first time or
with that organization the magnitude of
expectations that are there with the
celtics
um it it gives me a lot of inspiration
it gives me a lot of excitement and uh
you know i wish them both well at the
end of the day
steph the greatest shooter of all time
could be i played with a really good one
in ray allen um but yeah if they head to
head
sorry i'll probably have to put my money
if i said bird ray
steph
to win the game
oh i'm going with larry legend
oh
i'm going with larry i'm sorry larry at
6 9 6 10 with that strap he had on his
arm
did he
did he do damage to you
larry you know i grew up in saginaw
michigan as a detroit piston fan
and so magic johnson being permission
was always my favorite player but the
pistons were always my favorite team and
man some of those piston celtic battles
in the 80s i'm of a certain age i'm
dating myself now but
i fell in love with the game in 80s and
i thought you had some of the best nba
basketball some of the best match-ups
uh some of the best college ball also
but
those those celtics man with bird
mikhail paris dennis johnson all those
guys i hated danny ainge
like
jerry season yeah yeah like all those
guys i still laughed with uh cedric
cornbread maxwell when we when we were
playing them in the series and
that was that man i hated those guys man
everybody in the state hated this
especially now i'm a laker it's even
it's deepened even more
great to talk to you and uh
congratulations good luck darvin
thank you so much dan great seeing you
at starving ham the lakers head coach we
recorded that interview yesterday
got a big job ahead of him